shocking display of liberal intolerance
at Hunter College right up here in
Manhattan a professor caught on tape
cursing out a group of pro-life students
even physically trashing their display
this is violent you're triggering my
students I'm sorry about that no you're
not I mean you can't even
so you don't even know what that is
oh okay think that's bad this story just
got a whole lot more seriously crazy
take a look and look at this video shot
by the New York Post with whom we share
common ownership the professor
threatening the life of the post
reporter who showed up at her Bronx
apartment actually she's wielding that
Wicked looking machete holding it up to
the guy's throat
let's let's get out of here you can't do
that
nuts the college putting out a statement
saying quote Hunter College strongly
condemns no kidding the unacceptable
actions of chalene Rodriguez and has
taken immediate action Rodriguez has
been relieved of her duties at Hunter
College effective immediately will not
be returning to teach at the school we
have reached out to the professor and
her Union
who interestingly enough is uh
supporting her we have not heard we have
not heard back uh you know Jesse
reporters can be annoying but putting
the machete up to the guy's throat
has that ever happened to you
this is an attack on the freedom of the
press remember how many times we heard
that you think the media is going to
ever tell this story this is going to
get Waukesha paraded right off the front
page here's why you have a black female
college professor first of all
threatening
pro-life students and then you have her
holding a knife to a journalist's throat
everything about this story screams
you know what and they will Now cover
this thing up like they've done pretty
much every story that makes all of their
people look bad and I just want to know
one thing how did Hunter College
actually hire this person they had no
inkling that she was just crazy you're
saying this is the first time this ever
came to Hunter College's attention she's
insane but they knew she wasn't saying
it wasn't until they actually had the
video that they couldn't deny the fact
that the woman needs to be arrested for
menacing that is imminent that is a a
threat an imminent threat to another
human being she says she wants to chop
him up her it is clear she's violating
the First Amendment rights of those
students who have those leaflets on the
table she's also as far as I'm concerned
she's also creating a a belief on the
part of young students some of them
impressionable that when she says my
students you're triggering my students
so you've got at least want to rest and
a conviction right there turn the tape
on tell the jury to go in and deliberate
read them the law that's the end of it
the second thing is violating the First
Amendment rights of the students and the
third is she is creating this mentality
that you're triggering someone if you
disagree with what they think she should
never have been will she get indicted
she won't
she won't be indicted because it's a
misty misdemeanor but she should be
charged okay she should be arrested and
charged prosecuted convicted but you
know Daniel if you look at the video
again it's here's the dramatic one with
the machete to the neck but then go back
to the one if you can uh where she's uh
uh destroying the display of the
pro-life display that shows the anger
that is brewing there you know you could
tell that this is a bomb ready to go off
and it she's got issues we've got issues
I think that it's fair to say that so we
did this story this morning with Kennedy
and Kat on America's Newsroom before we
knew about the machete before the
machete thing happened so the story
escalated very quickly because because
but your point is Geraldo this is bad
enough these are students who have the
permission of the university to have
their table to have their leaflets to
basically peacefully say we are pro-life
and if you would like some more
information would you please take a
leaflet and she is a adult woman who
can't just walk by without a comment not
only not a comment but like trying to
destroy them and that and the young man
says oh I'm sorry no you don't have to
be sorry you don't you did the right
thing and you were poised and you were
gracious and just keep at it and this is
when your integrity gets tested the kids
didn't react the reporter didn't react
she has now to deal with the
consequences of her actions I'm glad you
brought that up got fired she has not
been fired as far as I as I read this
judge listen to this yeah the uh the
Provost has completed an investigation
she fired her and the faculty member has
been appropriately disciplined in
addition the faculty member has been
warned that if the behavior reoccurs oh
that that was no that was their first
thing
the other one was they they say that she
has been relieved I I gotta find that
yeah here it is right here yeah Hunter
College strongly condemns the
unacceptable actions of chalene
Rodriguez and has taken immediate action
Rodriguez has been relieved of her
duties at Hunter College effective
immediately and will not be returning to
teach at the school Hunter College is
part of City University does at the
school I you know I represented uh
teachers who've been fired and and with
some good results all right go to Ken
with some with some good results this
she could get hidden in the City
University of New York system oh they do
that all the time all the time so she's
not fighting I mean there are message
boards of parents not New York City
public schools because they take creeps
from one school where there have been
complaints and they just moved into
another school and they don't tell the
parents they don't even tell the other
teachers they certainly don't tell the
students but yes City University of New
York that is a giant institution and
they'll put her somewhere because her
Union what she did was unacceptable when
she went up to those students she tossed
the leaflet she swore at them she used
the f word and she was also very
transphobic she told one of those nice
young men that he can't have a baby and
in this world he can be a chess feeder
and I thought that was joke that was
very very cruel but yeah threatening
someone with a knife with a machete up
to their neck that is indefensible and
yes that is that's actionable the PSC
Graduate Center her labor union said it
stands by Rodriguez quote against
right-wing anti-abortion backlash yeah
so they think if you disagree with
someone that deserves violence that that
is absolutely what they think that's
what she thinks that's the union thinks
and that's why most colleges have gone
to hell I say that as a parent who's
sending a child to college in the fall
and we are going to have some
conversations about standing up for
yourself and your beliefs and
compromising those beliefs whenever you
want to get an end and we're seeing
right here that Columbia University has
just hired the machete professor she's
going to be Hillary's ta the union added
that her actions were Justified
Justified Justified let's go out with
the machete video
other than a progressive D.A to come in
and say not in my city are you going to
hold a machete to a reporter that that
reporter the New York Post reporter who
got chased with the machete will be on
Hannity tonight at eight Eastern
definitely do not nine did I say eight
yeah
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now